ich werde ganz oft immer gefragt was
denn der Unterschied zwischen pflaumen
und Zwetschgen ist zum einen gibt es
natürlich den optischen Unterschied aber
natürlich sind sie botanisch schon
miteinander verwandt also ist es so
Pflaumen die sind eher die rundlichen
saftigen und aromatischen und Pflaumen
sind wirklich super geeignet um damit
Marmelade oder Chutneys zu kochen
optisch gefallen sie mir super gut
Samira und Ella die Essen die auch total
gerne aber Pflaumen haben das Problem
die kann man zum einen nicht so gut
entsteinen und zum anderen sind sie
einfach so wässrig dass sie den Kuchen
zum Beispiel sehr verwässern würden
deswegen gibt's Zwetschgen und
Zwetschgen die sind wirklich super die
haben auch meisten längliche Form und
lassen sich einfach viel einfacher
entsteinen guck mal da kriegt man den
Stein einfach so mit der Hand raus und
die sind einfach nicht so wässrig und
bleiben auch wenn sie erhitzt werden und
mitgekocht oder mit gebacken werden
einfach schön in Form